the end always fear is coming and the
blood will be on your hand the first
rule of Mission Impossible is making the
most immersive most subjective
experience that we can that's why Tom
Cruise performs all of his own stunts
and it's how we design all the sequences
to show that it's really Tom doing we're
putting you in that action with Ethan
Hunt the IMAX ratio gives me a lot more
freedom gives me a lot more top and
bottom and I can make something that is
that truly has an incredible sense of
scale the expanded aspect ratio normally
when you're watching a movie in
widescreen you're seeing it in what we
call - 400 and we expand it you're
actually taking it back much more image
there's that much more scope and scale
to the frame and it really makes a world
of difference when you see it it's
important to be premiering in an IMAX
with a simple reason that this is the
one opportunity that you have to see it
while it's in theaters I think for
audience is seeing a movie like IMAX on
the big screen you're gonna have a
hugely immersive experience you're gonna
see something that you've never seen
before in a way you've never seen it
you
you